les paniers sont pleins et les visites
moins fréquentes
certains consommateurs ont changé leurs
habitudes en temps de pandémie
je n'écrase pas quotidiennement avant je
n'ai deux ou trois fois à pied
maintenant avec une fois mais je prends
la voiture
depuis un mois la moitié des
consommateurs ont réduit le nombre de
leur visite à l'épicerie 50% dès qu'elle
attend des buts et une rhétorique et au
début de la crise
malgré toutes les mesures sanitaires mis
en place certains perçoivent les
magasins d'alimentation comme un lieu à
risque pour la transmission de lakovic
ces mesures représentent un coût pour
les épiciers à la fin de cette période
et on commence déjà à voir que nos coûts
d'opération sont astronomiques dans
cette épicerie comme dans d'autres il a
fallu s'ajuster un système de livraison
a été rapidement mise en place et du
personnel de surveillance a été embauché
un agent de sécurité est posté en tout
temps à l'entrée coûte de 3 à 4000 $ par
semaine ce qui n'était pas inclus dans
la comptabilité de l'entreprise avant la
pandémie
pour l'instant les propriétaires absorbe
les freezers facilite la vie forcément
du consommateur ça nous aide au niveau
aussi de l'hygiène mais c'est un très
très gros impact sur les frais de cartes
de crédit que le curieux que l'on est
obligé d'absorber et que tous les
commerces vont absorber la faiblesse du
dollar canadien se reflète dans le prix
des fruits et légumes
on constate aussi une légère hausse au
comptoir des viandes avec les coûts
opérationnels à la hausse dans les
supermarchés la courbe de nos dépenses
en épicerie ne devrait pas s'appeler tir
de sitôt ici car la oliveira radio
canada montréal